hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at [ __ ]
boys 3 now like I said in the last
episode I'm not gonna be taking another
shot because I know my limit and I just
want to reiterate I'm not here to
promote excessive drinking I'm here just
to have a good time and hopefully
entertain you guys for a little bit
longer and I think this actually might
be like the last episode so if we get
through it in this one you might be cool
it all of that but until we do that we
need to actually get to the boy where
we're going to be things so I'm gonna
beat this guy into the ground I've been
killing all of your other appendages has
been like cutting off your limbs err I
just spit almonds all over my screen I
was eating almonds before this I was
getting a little hungry I've been like
playing this for like a long time now
thankfully it hasn't crashed since I did
not I did not I did not heal or renew my
[ __ ] Ryan I need to get it together
because I'm not focusing at all I like
went out the room came back whoa okay
well that sounds gonna be oh oh alright
I see how it is okay so hopefully I
saved yeah I did okay so what I need to
do is yes bloo-bloop okay and now little
loop okay we're good we're good we're
good
let me save here just game to die again
I don't think it's gonna happen because
I'm gonna kick his ass
yes please do what happen to shadow
Freddy wears shadow Freddy can he help
me out again because shadow fraida was
kind of Awesome I know I'm sick of your
[ __ ] to just let me get this over with
so that we can get on with our lives
oh whoa what did I do that on building
toss room seven I'm gonna kill you first
that's what I'm gonna do oh it didn't
hurt ah dinner Oh marijuana smoke really
what where's my Oh
oh that's not what I was doing I was
going for I gotta be so rude
do what I want you to do uh-huh No ah
there we go boom Oh oh good
wow man if that didn't kill him I would
have been owner owned like bangerang but
phone the road okay you're done
Jesus damn it these a-holes here I
[ __ ] did to get my [ __ ] so with that
being said like that's what I that's why
I think this might be the last part
because it's gonna roll right through
these fairly quickly so once I do that I
am actually in the free and clear
correct whoa
do I have to go back for that ah I don't
know where these chests are appearing I
I'm just
whoo hey I'm close my god
fine [ __ ] you oh Jesus I didn't even see
him the last time that's the chest back
here no good but I know there's like two
chests in the attraction now unless like
one spawns and then the other D spawns
it's entirely possible that's a thing
let me actually let me since there's no
like enemies there's no harm in just
going and finding it Freddie my [ __ ]
soul is gone Freddie Freddie Freddie -
trading my money oh is that gonna help
you I'm golden freddie bronze equipment
cool what does that mean bronze bronze
equipment I mean what is bronzing women
Oh Simon here what oh I already have the
darg and although I don't need that I
don't need it
okay I got I got I got it I got it okay
what was I was about to do something I
forgot oh yeah did I read this he was
simply a visual representation of what
the players collected not me personally
oh all right there golden Freddy sorry
Dee interrupts your important thing oh
then I don't need to get the chest
because I don't need any of the
equipment because I'm good unless
there's like other equipment that for
the other parts of my bar
okay so maybe maybe that's a thing so
would there be ah okay ah okay here we
go okay that's well that's what it is
okay that's what it is our I gotta gotta
gotta gotta getta getta getta getta
getta getta getta getta giddy
okay so with that being done now I can
continue smashing into the cameras
without taking too much damage because I
was getting my [ __ ] wrecked by that guy
even though I have the dragon dildo oh
wait not yet hey I guess II even though
I had the dragon dunno though I kind of
got hurt alot so I'm not gonna do that
hmmm what you say something huh yeah
you're scared now you're scared now
Oh your balloons you come find me with
balloons I don't care how many you pull
out of your ass doesn't matter they're
dead okay uh yes yes oh yeah huh huh huh
damn it
ah he was almost dead goddamn it I was
so close all right whatever it don't
matter cuz I know you're done you're
done
dinner dinner dinner didn't the
nananananana bonk oh that should have
killed him before but I don't know age
like beggars can't be choosers it was
gonna do what its gonna do I need to
know I don't need you I'm good
they can't kill me I highly doubt the
vision kill me oh if it's gonna be like
this jeez let me just I might as well I
I need I need an extra large actually
oh I better not use those oh [ __ ] I
better not use my extra large I may need
them at the end of this ah yes I
shouldn't have done that
oh I'm not smart oh no damage come on
just cuz I'm blind doesn't mean not
gonna hit him oh stop being blind
thank you thank you very much douche
nozzle okay
yay pizza slices exactly what I needed
not yeah I did it I went there oh yeah
ichael the only problem is I have to
heal myself after it whew
oh another flashback baby we were such
best friends I'm going to have a night
of debauchery and I just debauchery so
intense and amazing that the universe
will implode can I come
Oh oh that's so mean
well you gotta be so mean to him he's a
nice bear well not really he won't say
yep some dicks
apparently so I've heard through the
rumor mill he's kind of it kind of kind
of likened a you fussing books okay and
I need to make sure that I don't screw
all this up because if I run out I might
be boned Hays work
now that golden Freddy's here no okay
fine then on my way next camera thank
you oh absolutely yes okay still I am
scared you still scared cuz you can't
seem to stop me
it's Golden Bear okay that's a lot of
things I would like to have an ability
that allows me to not have to deal with
all that
now whatever I'll just kill you it may
take a couple tries oh okay they don't
worried that bad all right we're still
good we're still good
oh damn it with the marijuana ah okay at
least that did the thing okay but now oh
god damn it oh they gonna kill me oh no
oh no oh no I don't want to use an
extra-large but he did a lot of damage I
think that's just cuz I was like frozen
oh no he's gonna kill me oh no he's
gonna kill me ah [ __ ] damn it why did he
have to blow smoke in my face just when
I was needing that not have smoke blown
in my face right whatever fine fine fine
fine I get it I get it I get it try
again cuz I did something wrong
apparently
going down buddy uh-huh uh-huh okay this
time no foolin
don't dick with me I won't dick with you
except when I kill you
uh-huh oh did I not heal up come on
I thought I saved after I healed up this
is punch of bollocks
ah what a bunch of [ __ ] I just kill me
already what a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
it's a [ __ ] balls and tits wanker yes
gotcha baby I need to be more mindful of
this [ __ ] I mean the only reason I did
that is because I lucked out and he
didn't blow smoke in my face cuz I'm an
idiot
I also didn't have to use that large
pizza but it was only to play safe so
that I had a chance cuz I don't have a
chance then I'm screwed
come on
Oh evade you piece of [ __ ] stop that the
more damage I take the more apt to heal
afterward the more items I waste and the
more I am likely to die give up okay
there we go god I got a got a good good
good oh forget the DD bossy yes Oh a
chest appeared somewhere in the
attraction but we're probably behind me
probably behind me because that's the
way I knew it I knew it
okay Gold equipment was found so with
that I should be able to do this I
should be able to do that I should be
able to do this and I don't know how
much worse okay it's way worse so I
don't even know how I'd be able to do
this with the equipment that it's been
giving me there's no way that I would be
able to accomplish it because frankly
Jesus Rickon hard whoa difficulty 5 why
why is that one difficulty five thank
you for coming mother [ __ ] alright I
guess I don't know why the other room is
a lower difficulty than this one yeah
what do you guys say to me hi
or you I'll be back when I kick his ass
there we go yes yes yes yes dead dead
dead gotta gotta got it wasted another
item hey it is what it is all I need to
do now is just mop up the rest of em and
I'll be good hopefully oh come on why am
i blind
sassafras oh come on
ah I'm seriously gonna be boned over if
I have to hold onto all these items
towards the end of this like level
adventure that I'm doing because if I do
that I'm going to run out and then I'm
gonna have nothing left here we go
another one what do you have to say to
me why are you clever okay he's dead now
I just got a mop up the rest of them
without dying like a douche which it
seems to me like my best quality I do
that very well okay there has to be a
way to get items because I'm getting all
these tokens I've got a lot of tokens
there has got to be a way to get items
because if there isn't then I'm
literally gonna be so bummed that I'm
not gonna be able to beat all the
cameras whoa Oh what is this the
cassette radar 2.0 was found what is
that what are you talking about I'm
serious Krystal that shines light on
hidden tapes okay so okay man alright
good thank you sir for that oh oh okay I
hope there's not one like hidden
underneath the mini-map cause that would
be okay okay okay
is that so okay all right oh what'd I do
what'd I do
deep in the recesses of golden Freddy's
mind something awakens
I have obtained the tapes it's time to
unveil the hollow shroud of lies it
covers a sinful earth okay what I am
ready what is happening to ascend to
become a rap god of course absolutely it
is my final destiny and only one person
stands in my way
what oh oh I was asking the same thing
because honestly I don't know
you know what I should just stop I
stopped asking that is that is way too
much damage that is way too much damage
required to beat this guy dammit god
dammit ah I don't have enough items I
could beat him if I had items where am I
gonna get items where do I get more
items what do I do to get more items
fine I'll get good god damn I don't even
remember if I got all the tapes I don't
think so
did I wait where am I I didn't even get
what I needed to get god dammit I
haven't saved in a long time I gotta
find like where do I get items what do I
do to get items what do I do
why are you offering me whatever me
hungry it's time to take a break
what wha what break break I like a break
does break mean items oh okay
oh yes oh you're not gonna if their digs
are you good animation great animation
love that love that a lot that's great
but what my order there is an attractive
che
I'll take a nice guffy oh you're a lot
shorter in burden why why oh oh I didn't
even do that much why maybe I'm taking
the wrong approach to this because for
all these battles that I'm in doing I
haven't been summoning anything so I'm
like like maybe I need to summon a lot
more and do everything else a lot less
and that's the last cassette that I'll
get before I just suddenly go into the
other dimension okay and let me try this
weird Biggie Smalls thing okay so here
we go I'm gonna try this with the effort
of summoning things as opposed to doing
what I was doing before which may have
been stupid and not correct I just
needed to build up stack yeah that's why
it went on for like I don't know five
six minutes and I only did that much
damage to him but I was lasting a lot
longer by summoning creatures so maybe
that's what I've been doing wrong this
whole time
either way I really don't know how to
get items it's like good point
oh god dammit this is gonna go to
freakin Starbucks again oh oh no oh oh
oh items items please please oh please
let me have items I need items so badly
there's so many items and oh yes finally
oh my god oh I'm so happy oh it's about
damn time oh oh oh I was so worried I
thought I wasn't gonna be able to
complete the game oh that's so much
better
is that so hard probably okay alrighty
then there we go
whoo all right great
I have items I finally have items now it
can be Biggie Smalls
come on baby come on yes
oh that took forever that was like over
a 10 minute fight right there but I did
it damn it
I don't even know what that was worth
why did I do that I [ __ ] did it even
my [ __ ] don't Freddie became a rap god
what is that an alternate ending oh okay
good for me I did it whoop Dee frickin
do what was the point of that ah I don't
know at least I know now that I can
capably beat all the cameras it should
be easy at this point you know I'm just
gonna finish it up I've been I've been
playing a long time but I've been
okay literally right as I said I was
gonna keep playing this game my game
crashed and then I accidentally hit
space and stopped my audio recording so
it's all started back up I am gonna
finish this game and I'm gonna finish it
all in one now there's only uh there's
only two cameras left as far as I know
I'm so glad that there's no reason for
me to beat biggie like that why did I
bother why did I have to bother why did
I have to care okay either way I'm good
this guy's going down and then we're
gonna get to the bottom of this and
we're gonna get to the end of this cuz I
said so that's why
hello how are you boom baby done done
done done so done so is Yuzo and I'm not
even blind or anything so I don't have
to worry about that and these [ __ ]
don't even do anything so I don't have
to worry about them okay okay
dum dum dum dum that was easy that was
easy I was so so easy I did it yeah it
wasn't even a problem now because I got
a lot of items and I had a lot of luck
in the last 100 another flashback oh
it's going to happen
my [ __ ] debate Oh No
how did golden lose MLG Pro compilation
incoming uh-huh
what whatever you intercepted the mail
okay
why oh you're fired
uh-huh oh well maybe you spring-trap ah
someone defended that you said yes when
they wrote the [ __ ] complain ah man
how could they and oh you already said
that you made me feel bad in my heart
hole I can't believe it either
excuse my bit spring-trap you always
ruin fredbear fuckboys diner for me
uh-huh you you yeah debauchery pan out
to here with the war
okay oh okay
that makes sense I'm happy about that -
cool
damn oh it's time I knew he's done I
know I know I'm well aware of this I
wasn't afraid before I was afraid when I
didn't have items but that wasn't really
fear that was like rational logical
approaching of the problems that I had
okay weird music that's coming in on the
final part here not gonna question it
just gonna do my job and be done with it
oh I can't move okay I'm not even gonna
talk to you Bonnie I know you're not
gonna do anything what if those like the
one moment that Bonnie actually was
gonna respond like problem probably and
I just screwed myself over by not
talking to him I killed biggie but I
didn't talk to Bonnie therefore I'm not
gonna get the good ending everyone's
gonna be mad at me
whoa that's a difficult camera something
tells me that seems a little unfair
hello hi oh no he's the ball oh okay
uh-huh uh-huh
oh how is it ha ha ha all right whatever
you know what let's try this let's get
past camera a dead do this to pass
camera B damn neighborhood they are
desert punk punk oh you do have a lot of
health ok I got you
alrighty then ok I'll just lay in the
past camera a first uh now ah piss god
damn it Oh party yet ah I thought the
party ants were fast
god damn it [ __ ] duck god damn it ok be
back
come on you big bastard I'm gonna get
you
yes spear that spoken ain't gonna do
growl oh hell yeah that took a long time
- that wasn't a minute fight hot damn
hot damn I did it I'm the best look at
me I'm good oh yeah it was [ __ ] yeah oh
yeah oh yeah
exploding pieces now it's all over it
damn do it again
spring-trap Odin to stop to pay for your
debauchery I'm gonna gift
you're [ __ ] yeah everybody cheer for
the upcoming Giffen ah I can't believe I
was done with this alright think I'm
almost done if I'm not almost done I
would have liked my goodness what else
could there be
I don't think I need to get any more
items because still have like a ton of
crap wait maybe yeah I guess why not
I've got so many em as well man this
fight is gonna take a long time nothing
hello again with the music of earthbound
get my [ __ ] agree yes I've been
expecting you Fred but exactly I know
cuz you've been watching me on the
cameras oh hey nice shoes oh [ __ ] oh oh
yeah little that swag oh [ __ ] uh-huh
for what oh why are you helping baby
who's gonna be inhaling now oh you
this is where you eat my [ __ ] oh is it
now I think you're sorely mistaken No
this is perfectly a family violence
this is from 1972 oh oh it's on
I hope I don't die because it's gonna
take a long time to get back to this
fight spring top appeared Fanta baby
appeared okay oh yeah yeah oh no no you
gonna die oh I don't think so because I
got all my Bros on my side and I know
how to beat you probably I don't know
maybe maybe I do maybe I don't
ba ba ba ba the only thing I can do that
might put someone to sleep is for frappe
okay you go down you go down
ah poison spring-trap
then you will try to realign yep okay
there's gonna be a long involved fight
I'll pop in here and there to check in
and we're going what to be honest I
don't really know what I'm doing but um
Oh Oh that all we deal with oh they
don't have all that much shelf Oh
blinded baby
yes exactly what beat me to sleep
critical it 90 damage holy hell come on
sleep come on yes asleep is a sleep it
worked
[ __ ] you baby all right it's so double
blinded okay so now I just got to focus
straight on spring-trap what no no no no
be sick of this [ __ ] I'm winning oh
you're just gonna rage quit when I'm in
the middle of my victory okay
what is this part of your 9:00 in
debauchery
oh now everything's on fire oh I gotta
beat you within a time limit or
something oh I see how this is oh I see
how this is okay oh it's really starting
to fall down isn't it oh yeah what do I
do about that am I supposed to actually
do something it's better not turning
into a game over situation because I
will be very pissed
okay bebés awake oh [ __ ] my allies are
falling like flies okay
let me summon another one just to get
another body in here may fall down soon
but at least I'll have someone in here
what what oh come back here BB yeah shut
up I'm gonna take you down yeah you're
mine now you're done just give me one no
come on I'm right there oh no no no no
no no no no no no no no no don't do this
to me don't do this [ __ ] I was gonna win
a new local attraction based on an
ancient pizzeria chained burnt down
overnight was how it was supposed to
happen
authorities have not ruled out foul play
but at the moment it seems to have been
caused by faulty wiring of animatronics
very little was found at the scene the
few items that were salvaged was to be
sold at public this is exactly the end
of five nights at freddy's 3
ah that's the end Oh was that supposed
to happen oh my god if that was supposed
to be the way it is that is really
really cool
oh that's cool
but I almost had him if I just had one
more turn it'd probably take him to
mortars but I almost had him ah damn it
oh god damn it I mean I guess it's
supposed to be meant that way because I
mean even if you don't have the dragon
dildo you definitely would have been
able to do it but I had the dragon devil
the best out of the best weapon I could
have gotten at that point and I still
couldn't finish him off and I was just
like hammering as hard as I could I feel
like that left things undone but hey I
didn't find the true endings on the
first two games either because I don't
want to keep drinking to get to them so
I guess that's the end oh I guess that's
the end hang on I got away through the
end of the credits BRB oh-oh-oh-oh
everybody keep that password safe write
it down write it down right now remind
me of it later for some reason okay that
number remember that that's the end I
guess I guess I'm not sure though
probably not cuz I didn't I didn't have
the way open to me which might have been
like the way out of the fire I don't
know I guess that's it I can't I can't
do anything else
hey that's the end of 590 [ __ ] boiserie
that was incredible I mean it took a
long time but damn that was like a super
involved thing I had a story and
everything knows way better than the
first two in the first you were good
oh man I guess that's it so let me know
what you think of this in the comments
below obviously I miss things and I'm
not gonna get drunk again just to find
it or play through the game again but
there you have it if you want to find
out for yourself I highly recommend
playing this game it takes a lot of
grinding and takes a lot of strategy but
hey like the combat actually matters in
the game and the story was actually
interesting it was funny too I'm really
glad you guys decided to stick with me
for this long there's been one of the
longest recording sessions that I've
done several hours has went into
drinking taking shots and playing a game
which is a lot of fun for me so next I
gotta edit it which is slightly less fun
because I know there's gonna be a lot of
crap that I need to cut out and make
sure that
songs are a-ok but I really hope you
enjoy this one thank you for sticking
with me thank you for supporting me and
thank you for watching and enjoying
these videos and if you played the
drinking game after I uploaded this I'll
put all the parts I hope you get a good
night's sleep those thank you everybody
so much for watching check out the other
hand tasters for more five nights at
Freddy's 5 nights of [ __ ] boys funny
games scary games I've got it all I have
over 2000 videos on my channel there's
some seriously cool stuff for you to
check out maybe you'll get a laugh out
of it thanks again everybody and as
always I will see you in the next
you go about you without any food please
what